[Applause]
you're watching sub white here's a
little piece of what we've got for you
on this week's show Thomas finds out how
we could soon be printing our furniture
I get a surprise from a tech magician
and we've got the new video game
described as the first of its kind
[Music]
that's all to come over the next ten
minutes after a quick roundup of some of
this week's tech news Russia and China
are tightening internet controls by
banning software that could keep users
anonymous both countries are clamping
down on Virtual Private Networks or VPNs
which can help users to access sites
that may have been blocked by their
internet providers human rights groups
have criticized the moves four and five
UK adults for now binge watching TV
series with catch-up and streaming
services continuing to grow in
popularity that's despite a third saying
they lose sleep staying up watching
Ofcom also found young people are
watching a third less live TV than they
were seven years ago and Spotify now has
60 million paying subscribers it added
ten million in less than five months
according to the streaming company
pushing its lead further ahead of rival
Apple music stay with us because still
to come I'll introduce you to one of the
first magicians to specialize in
manipulating technology and there's a
trick in store for us I just want to
show you something I've had Apple just
sent it to us but first technology and
design have gone hand in hand for
decades and this week Thomas has been to
meet a team using 3d printing to create
household furniture
3d printing has become part of the
everyday new and more complex techniques
are being developed all the time and
it's even in the hands of creatives like
3d artist grace who uses the world's
first 3d pen 3doodler to create a
variety of different objects let's think
a little bigger
for example furniture could we soon be
printing tailor-made couches tables and
desks for our homes well that's the
opinion of one team from the
architecture school at University
College London they've created this the
voxel chair an entire chair created from
a single piece of extruded plastic is
the combination of high-end visual
design and cutting-edge technology the
project itself demanded a whole new
software program be developed one
exclusively for 3d printing for the last
4 years we've been developing a research
in plastics plastic extrusion using
industrial robots at the UCL design
computation lab so what we are trying to
do is to allow different objects to be
inserted in this in this software and
we're working on how to make it a user
friendly and easy to understand
although slick-looking this software is
in its early stages of development but
once rolled out it could allow anyone to
visualize and create their own furniture
at home and it doesn't stop there the
software could even be used to take on
much larger projects the software will
allow to materialize things that we just
couldn't before
so in a few years from now imagine
larger objects to start appearing such
as walls pieces of a structure
for now the Vauxhall chair remains
unique it's set to go on display as a
piece of design history after being
bought by the Pompidou Center in Paris
so could we see a whole voxel house in
the future you could have completed
their box whole environment in the
future in the near future
yes watch this space Thomas Newton Sky
News
now when I say magician what's the first
thing that comes to mind I bet it's not
a smartphone some magicians these days
are going digital like tom london who's
been a contestant on America's Got
Talent
I met up with him and I began by asking
what it means to be a tech magician have
you seen these iPad pros is this really
cool new feature Apple just announced in
the day you can just grab things like
this if you get more wiggle and slide
them out isn't it crazy for me it's
about that classic arthur c clarke quote
you know any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
so I find there's this magic in
technology advanced technology is
something impossible can be achieved
with with tech and how did you end up as
a tech magician I'm a programmer and a
coder so my backgrounds always been tech
as in gadgets so I would see a magic
trick
I'd see someone perform some magic or
maybe an illusion and immediately my
mind would work it would think how could
I do all of that using technology one of
the biggest complaints people have about
technology is when it fails on them if
it fails for you it ruins the trick how
do you cope happens all the time
it really does so I mean I've been up
countless nights before before shows you
know like coding something and it's just
not working and there's this that you
know in the back of your mind that
there's a 50% chance it's gonna go wrong
in the day say you have to have
contingency plans you know do you want
to tell us what your name is please yeah
Tom London you spend a lot of your time
in the States because you've been a
contestant on America's Got Talent
yeah do you think there are differences
in the way Americans compared to British
people view technology
oh yeah entirely yes definitely
how many millions of records do you
think Mel and when she performed the
Spice Girls sold worldwide starters in
America everywhere you go there's a
television screen you know if a rational
you're going to televisions everywhere I
think Americans in general are taught to
switch off a bit more when they see the
screens their mind kind of just diverts
so how does that affect your magic with
them yeah well that's the thing
my job is to try and direct their
attention towards this technology and
their subconscious is telling them to
look away and what you guys to see this
bit what effort with Americans to be
like watch this just don't look away
watch it and they're like we're good to
go I'm really keen to see a trick yeah
is it anything you can do for us okay
here's what we do we're gonna take a
selfie together okay you have to copy me
so like this grab your phone and hands
like that yeah yeah and put the put the
hand on you there like that perfect all
right here's our MIDI I'm just gonna do
a cross on my thumb like this can you
see that I wanted to watch the cross
very carefully to stare at the cross
yeah yeah I'm just gonna pinch it like
this you see okay yeah unlock your fine
see look if you open up Twitter I'm
verified so I should be the top but
you'll see there's a fighter that I just
tweeted of you oh look I see shadow
camera you've got the cross in your hand
right the grass is on my hand but here's
what's crazy look on the back of your
hand your left hand it's magic
oh my goodness look no idea
utterly mind-blowing anyway this video
games time now and this week Lucy has
been back in the studio here she is with
her pick of the latest releases you very
happy paya is the latest game from
Bastion and transistor developer
supergiant games and it's basically it's
it's a sport game but with a lot of
characterization and a lot of deep
elements that you have to really dig
into
[Music]
you play the game as an exile and you
lead a group of other exiles through
this wasteland and you're basically
trying to earn your own freedom and the
way you do that is by participating in
these religious rites which take the
form of it's kind of a simplified
version of maybe basketball or football
and that you have to get your glowing
orb ball thing into the other team's
goal which sounds very very simple but
once you get into the game you find that
all your different characters not only
do they have their own backstories and
different relationships they have their
own abilities that you can use on the on
the field and if they win it's basically
like gladiator you're fighting to earn
your freedom
I definitely think is really worth a
play
[Music]
hell-blade sinews sacrifice is the
latest game from a developer called
ninja Theory who are in Cambridge and
Ninja Theory specialized in these hack
and slash games but what what's
interesting about Hell blade is the
world in which it takes place so it's
kind of this mashup of Celtic and Nordic
mythology and you play as sanur and it's
not just like regular enemies in the
world the world has been tainted by her
psychosis if you will so all these
manifestations these auditory
hallucinations you get to kind of play
that it's a very interesting look at
mental health and games so the
developers have been working closely
with people who actually suffer from
psychosis as well as neuroscientists to
make sure that they're giving this
really it really good an accurate
representation in this video game if you
go online you can see how they've
developed the game and how they've made
it and one thing they've really focused
on is motion capture so if you go to
their YouTube channel or look at any of
their trailers you can see just how well
they've managed to capture the actress
and put her straight in the game so if
you're looking for something that's
action heavy but a little different and
with a little bit more of a story to
tell then I definitely recommend
hell-blade
I'm headed in welcome aboard
Tacoma is the latest game from Fulbright
who specialized in environmentally rich
games that require you to walk around
and explore your environment pick up
every last item and examine it and just
to sort of tell the story through the
environment Tacoma is really cool
because your technician and you go to
this abandoned space station but in this
space station there is this AI that's
been sort of monitoring all the crew and
you know listening into all that
conversations recording it but by the
time you get there the crew has been
long gone the space stations abandoned
and you're there to try and fix things
up but the AI has sort of it recreates
the final days of of the space station
by broadcasting these really colorful
Holograms they kinda look like something
from Tron and you live the lives of
these characters and you overhear their
conversations you read their notes and
it's just as something that you can take
take your time to sort of investigate
and if you want to play something a
little more low-key if you want to just
relax and play something then Tacoma is
a really engaging story that you can
definitely dig into
that's it for this week's show join us
again next week for more swipe and in
the meantime follow us on Twitter at sky
news swipe and you can stay up to date
with everything we get up to you
throughout the week see you again soon
bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]